l'un des grands projets du plan
université 2000 et s'achever ce plan
avait été mis en place par lionel jospin
quand il était ministre de l'éducation
il prévoyait notamment la création d'une
grande bibliothèque pour l'université de
saint-denis c'est donc chose faite et sa
bibliothèque est l'une des plus grandes
et des plus modernes de france isabelle
dupont jacques gauthier la nouvelle
bibliothèque de paris 8 n'est ouverte
que depuis trois semaines mais les
étudiants de la faculté s'y sentent déjà
comme chez eux
l'endroit est calme lumineux est vaste
quinze mille mètres carrés pour 1500
places de lecture c'est quatre fois plus
que ce que pouvait offrir l'ancienne
bibliothèque universitaire qui travailla
de l'espace contrairement à l'ancienne
on n'y trouvait pas assez de place et on
est obligé de s'asseoir par terre pour
étudier il réécrit un réseau
informatique est intéressant je connais
rien à l'informatique et j'ai réussi à
trouver un livre c'est simple facile
d'accès et je suis contente ans répartis
sur deux niveaux autour d'un pôle
central la bibliothèque dispose de sept
salles de lecture thématiques
identifiées par des couleurs différentes
dans chaque salle les lecteurs peuvent
accéder au catalogue informatisé
cent cinquante mille ouvrages sont en
accès libre 250 mille autres stockées en
magasin cofinancé par le département et
l'état
la bibliothèque de paris 8 n'est pas
réservé aux étudiants
tout le monde ici que d'emprunter enfin
correspond à la conception de
l'université quelques universités qui a
toujours été très ouvert un équipement
de ce type si vous voulez quelqu'un très
vaste et peut accueillir d'autres
lecteurs que l'électeur purement
universitaire sont à deux pas du futur
terminus de la ligne 13 de métro
l'université de saint-denis et ses
vingt-six mille étudiants constituent
désormais un pôle essentiel de
l'enseignement supérieur le ministre de
l'éducation claude allègre qui devait
inaugurer la bibliothèque lundi a annulé
officiellement pour raison de calendrier